the lead detective investigating the
hazing death of a Penn State student
believed someone tampered with crucial
evidence he testified yesterday that
hours of surveillance video from a frat
house basement was deleted on purpose
that's where Timothy Piazza was found in
February Anna Warner is in Bellefonte
Pennsylvania where the preliminary
hearing in the case is entering its
fifth day Anna good morning good morning
while this hearing is to determine
whether prosecutors have enough evidence
to support the charges against 16 of the
defendants but the investigation isn't
finished and more charges could be
coming relating to the missing
videotaped moments Centre County
District Attorney Stacy parks Miller
suspects someone tampered with the
basement surveillance cameras at the
Beta Theta Pi House to get rid of
evidence
you're saying right now video was
deleted that is a belief where we're
headed in this investigation we will not
say who it would be or that we're
willing to file charges until we have a
forensic report back on the stand State
College police detective David Chicano
did not identify a suspect
Piazza died in February following an
initiation ceremony that involved heavy
drinking security footage showed him
stumbling and hitting his head
repeatedly
he was found the following morning in
the basement Piazza family attorney Tom
Klein what was the stunning revelation
today is that there actually was a
videotape in the basement which was
likely erased and if that tape was
erased
then this cover-up is even larger than
we ever had anticipated or expected or
known about 18 members of the now
shuttered Beta Theta Pi fraternity have
been charged ten faced misdemeanors like
hazing furnishing alcohol to minors or
reckless endangerment two of the ten
waived their right to the preliminary
hearing the others face additional
charges of involuntary manslaughter and
aggravated assault
Leonard Ambrose represents Joseph Salem
one of the eight defendants charged with
the most severe crimes he says
prosecutors overcharged his client what
would the appropriate charge be
well the appropriate charge really for
everybody would be an underage
consumption of alcohol I mean that was
it
and the question of course is whether
video from the basement might show not
only Piazza's falls down the stairs but
heavy drinking and activity from earlier
in the evening the prosecutor says she's
asked the FBI whether they can recover
any of that footage
but they haven't gotten back to her yet
on whether they'll be able to do so
Margaret Anna thank you